you talked about
uh signing nipsey i mean obviously aside
from being from the same area
how did you guys like how did that end
up you know happening
um and you told the story a lot before
so just kind of give us a quick you know
yeah
um my nephew td i was looking for
artists
td told me to go get nip i went seek
nipped out
out of all the people we had already i
already been interviewing and talking to
and he was the signing light he was the
diamond in a pile of whatever
right it was a diamond let me respect to
my other homies he was a diamond
in a pile of other diamonds but he just
he just he was a bigger diamond he was a
sign yeah yeah he was and and then um
he was the vvs yeah
and we had made a couple of moves and
was trying to move through a couple of
doors and i vastly found out
that i couldn't go through these doors
so i swear i wouldn't got steve lobel
and um i went and got steve let steve
hear the music
steve felt the same way i felt about the
music and
i was like boom so i assigned nissi to
unique music to my uh
to um to arie mr astrodome to my to my
label to unique music
and then steve was 10 percent management
and i was 10 percent managers didn't
make no sense
to go get another management right and
so we started pushing on that
so i signed him to it was assigned to a
10-year production contract which
started in
2009 which would end 2019.
crazy hello but uh
i ain't tripping out for that because
you know it is what it is
but i do have that you know i mean so
wait so so your your deal with nipsey
was 10 years
10 years it was a 10. 10 continue 25
percent of publishing to arie miss
astrodome
oh wow so 09 to 2019 209 to 2019.
so technically victory lap hello okay
wow wow